Glenn Greenwald is an independent
journalist his work is on substack he
joins us tonight Glenn thanks so much
for coming on there's something about
the unwillingness of people to
acknowledge the obvious there was a
candidate whose views I really liked who
had a performance like that like
federman's performance I hope I'd be
honest enough to say you know I agree
with the guy but that was disqualifying
there's something about the
unwillingness to admit what everyone
knows is true that oh it's it's chilling
it's it's scary
yeah I think it's a form of power you
know so often George Orwell was so
prescient in what he predicted about how
authoritarianism and tyranny would work
and in 1984 the novel we all read in
high school and his warning about how
authoritarianism what happened he
described a tyrannical party and he
described as their final and most
essential command that you are to ignore
the evidence of your own eyes and ears
if you can get a citizenship citizenry
to do that to trust what they're told
more than what they're seeing and
hearing on their own that is a
population that is put into extreme
subservient and I think at on some level
the media almost likes being this Brazen
in their lives remember when we all
witnessed Joe Biden who we've seen in
public life for 50 years so obviously
suffering cognitive decline they decided
to tell us it wasn't really cognitive
decline that he had a stutter a stutter
that was never there before half the
time he doesn't know where he is half
the time he falls asleep been interviews
now and if you raise any of these things
we're told you're a big people who
stutter this is what they're doing now
they completely got caught lying they
attacked this young reporter for doing
what her job is but which they see as a
crime which is reporting things
derogatory or damaging to the Democratic
party and now they just are so Brazen
about it that they're going to insist
that what you're seeing is not really
what you're seeing I think that's
exactly right that's the heart of it
it's it's Earl's observation thank you
for pointing that out that if they can
make you
ignore something you know is true then
they have control over you completely
you're a Slave Glenn Greenwell thank you
very much thanks Tucker